stitch this and please explain to me what you mean by marriage is hard
I've touched on this topic so many times
that I have a playlist about marriage in my profile
I've been with my husband for 12 years
married for 10
and my marriage is not hard
life is hard
we've gone through UPS and downs with finances
we've gone through having three babies together
we've gone through me having postpartum anxiety and mental health issues
we've gone through injuries
we've moved and renovated houses
but not once
during all of those hard moments
did I ever think gosh
being married is hard
in all honesty
if I hadn't been married
all of those things would have been about a million times harder
the caveat I think though
is that people get married for all sorts of reasons
and I have found that the relationship that I have with my husband
is the exception
not the rule
for one reason or another
people marry people that they have a really hard time cohabitating with
and coexisting with for long term
and maybe their relationship was a struggle from the beginning or maybe
I don't know
people change and grow
and they don't grow together
they grow apart
and that is totally possible
but the most beautiful thing in my life is my marriage
we have grown together through each stage of being together
and I hope we have nice
long lives that we continue to grow and change
and support each other
because we are each other's best friends and biggest supporters
and there's nothing better in this life than going through it with somebody who
you know is always going to be your person
so no I can't relate to marriage being hard either